der dihadismus befindet sich auf dem
Vormarsch seit der intensiven
Reaktivierung des Konflikts zwischen der
Hamas und Israel nehmen die Anschläge
islamischer radikale wieder wöchentlich
Platz in den internationalen Nachrichten
ein Ägypten und China waren unter den
ersten aber Europa ist leider nicht
zurückgeblieben das neue Gesicht des
jihadistischen Terrorismus das Europa
seit dem Aufstieg von daesh beherrscht
die Rede ist von der Figur des einsamen
Wolfs der einsame Wolf das heißt eine
Person die sich eigenständig
radikalisiert hat und keinen oder nur
begrenzten Kontakt zu terroristischen
Zellen hatte war in erster Linie für
Terroranschläge in Europa verantwortlich
weil ihr Kontakt zu Terrorzellen
manchmal gleich null ist und sich ihre
Entdeckung daher viel schwieriger
gestaltet stellen diese Terroristen die
größte Bedrohung für Europa da aus
diesem Grund versuchen die europäischen
geheimdienst- und Sicherheitsbehörden
seit einiger Zeit dieses Phänomen in
einem der Bereiche zu bekämpfen der die
meisten einsamen Wölfe hervorgebracht
hat soziale Medien und virtuelle Räume